Paterson Matt Gaetz represents the state
of Florida in the United States Congress
and we're happy to have him say
congressman thanks very much for coming
on so it's clear that in order to
restore public faith in the most
powerful institutions of government we
need to find out what happened here why
don't we know one of the reasons is that
we haven't had the Director of National
Intelligence dan coates actually lay out
for us what was in the transcripts taken
by the House Intelligence Committee
where they interviewed clapper where
they interviewed Comey and McCabe and
Brennan and we ought to have that
information he's been sitting on it for
four months and we need to get it out I
didn't know that over 50 transcripts
have been voted out of the House
Intelligence Committee to be
declassified so that we can get to the
bottom of where the lies existed and how
this terrible investment why hasn't
Coates made those public for months
we're still waiting but I think there's
a bigger problem in the Congress we have
to be able to rely on the intelligence
committee and the leadership of that
committee because as the American people
know every member of Congress does not
see every piece of intelligence I have
filed legislation today sense of the
house that Adam Schiff needs to be
removed from the Intelligence Committee
because how are the rest of us supposed
to be able to rely on a man who you just
showed lied to the American people when
he said that there wasn't spying or when
he lied and said there was actual
evidence of collusion or clear evidence
of collusion if Adam Schiff is able to
review covert operations and
intelligence and if we have to be able
to rely on his representations our whole
system is broken I mean it would be like
putting Lori Loughlin in charge of the
college board it would be like oh it's
right putting Jesse small ed in charge
of the hate crime division of the FBI
yeah we have got to remove Adam Schiff
from the intelligence thirty-five years
of watching in Congress I have never
seen a member of Congress with lower
personal integrity than Adam Schiff and
it's shocking to me that he chairs that
committee is there any hope of unseating
him from that I think that Nancy Pelosi
and just your rank-and-file democrats
have to feel the pressure from this
their constituents have to ask them how
are you going to be able to make
decisions in the best interest of our
country and our district if it's Adam
Schiff that you're listening to to get
characterizations and representations on
the quality of the intelligence and
whether or not it should justify
congressional action I want to just
explain to others we have on the screen
the name of this act the Penn slack
preventing extreme negligence with
classified information licenses for our
favorite pencil Tucker
that's exactly is there any I mean you
you stride the halls of Congress is
there any Democrat who behind-the-scenes
off-the-record joining to reveal names
agrees with you that a committee this
sensitive should not be chaired by
someone like Adam Schiff there are
Democrats in Congress who feel betrayed
because like the rest of the country
there was they were told that there was
actual evidence of collusion that this
was going to happen and a lot of those
very Democrats went out on a limb in the
campaign's right and promised their
voters that this evidence would be
turned up now we know the whole deal was
fake it was a lie and really I think a
lot of the narrative has been a cover-up
for the fact that under the Obama
administration our intelligence
community got so politicized at the
upper levels that they allowed political
opposition research to justify something
that should never happen in this country
and you're right it should never happen
from either side but the only way we're
going to be able to get to that solution
set is if we actually reform this
process that allows secret courts to be
able to abridge our rights and that's
something that we sort of signed up for
without thinking through it after 9/11
yeah but I think we're gonna be
rethinking and I think the American
people want to know how we got here and
they want to make sure we're never here
again how could you have a secret court
in a democracy and you don't even know
what the judges believe they go through
no public confirmation process and the
opinions are never made public
so even 20 years later you're unable to
ascertain what was the doctrine that was
guiding the most powerful tools in our
government to be turned against our
citizens in the absence of the
transparency that democracy requires
that is such a smart and true and good
point and I hope you will keep making it
thank you very much thank you